this might be one of the most absurd
films we've ever seen from the marvel
cinematic universe absurd it takes you
for a crazy ride and a lot of you are
gonna absolutely love it and some of you
are gonna go what did i just see what's
up everyone it's bobby back with you
here i just got out of the screening of
doctor strange and the multiverse of
madness uh the first screening in
singapore as a matter of fact and
wow
this is a wild ride this was not was
what i was expecting whatsoever now
disclaimer i did see the first 20
minutes of the film about a week ago and
i didn't do any sort of video on that
because i just wanted to sort of see the
entire film to kind of gather my
thoughts but this is a film that runs
about two hours and five minutes it is
well edited well paced it just moves
really quickly right out the back i mean
this thing just moves i mean you're
right into it and it takes you for a
ride in a way that we have never seen
from any marvel cinematic movie thus far
to date i will say this though i'm not
going to spoil the movie for you um
there are some cameos in there some have
leaked online some have not i'm not
going to get into all that stuff but i
will say that if you have not seen wanda
vision
watch one division before you watch this
or what if the two marvel shows that
were on disney plus because they are
essential to understanding this movie
you can get it without seeing those but
it will make a lot more sense if you did
see one division and you did see what if
because
there is a lot of elements of those two
shows kind of it's kind of almost like a
sequel of those two shows
in this movie um this is very much a
wanda scarlet witch film dr strange film
and those are pretty much the two
integral characters so if you're
thinking this is gonna be some you know
movie that's going to be you know
bringing all these new characters in
these new uh facets from marvel and all
these things i want to kind of
bring your expectations a little bit
down and it's not to say that's bad it's
not but marvel really what they do well
is they try to bring that human element
in there love what will someone do for
love
how far will they go
how far will they go this what would a
mother do to be with her children and
that is the essence of this film that's
not giving anything away because that's
in the trailer you already see it but
that is what this film is really about
there's some crazy spectacles going on
and it is fantastical and there's a lot
of horror elements coming into play i
mean it is a sam raimi film and it's
almost like you said sam
i want you to make a horror film your
style we're gonna give you the budget
you always dreamed of you're gonna use
doctor strange you can use scarlet witch
you can use wong and christina palmer
you have access to the multiverse
but make the film you've always wanted
to make that's a little bit a
little bit scary and just add something
new to the marvel cinematic universe and
that's exactly what raymie did now some
people love sam raimi films some people
are on the fence about them so if you
are one of those that love the evil dead
army of darkness you like the spider-man
one two and three you're going to really
enjoy this film because he does bring a
horror aspect to it but there's always a
little bit of that wink that like hey
we're having some fun here like don't
take it too seriously it's not a james
one con drink kind of a thing where it's
really like freaks the out of you
it's not that it is dark it's violent
it's
really creepy at times but you're also
laughing because a lot of times in the
audience people were just laughing out
loud at some moments in this i mean
there's elements where i was like am i
watching michael jackson's thriller
going on here is what's going on what is
happening here and there's other moments
where you're just like this is kind of
like a
70s 80s you know horror film
but obviously with much bigger budget
and it's got all those elements into it
but at the same time it still has the
heart
this video is brought to you by secret
lab here at geek culture we love our
secret lab chairs especially the all new
2022 titan evo with its revamped 4-way
lumbar system for enhanced back support
if p leather 2.0 isn't your cup of tea
then consider the all-new soft weave
even more soft and breathable than
before the chair comes in more colors
including this lovely frost blue the
titan evo is even magnetized allowing
the head pillow to stick on the headrest
without straps of course there are even
more new features so do check them out
at secretlab.com
and i think that's one of the things
getting into um the scarlet witch or
wanda maximoff what elizabeth olsen does
so well in this film
is she brings the heart i mean
she's such a phenomenal actress she
really is and if you had any other actor
out there that didn't have the quality
of the caliber that she had playing
scarlet witch this would not work
because we saw her in one division being
such a you know loving mother to her two
children even though they were
technically real but that
motherly instinct that she has that she
just brings to the screen it's just
it breaks your heart in many ways uh
benedict cumberbatch doctor strange once
again has knocked it out of the park
he's very funny in this film he's got
him i mean he's always a little bit you
know quick-witted and he's you know but
he's very funny in these moments and he
i mean sometimes the jokes work and
sometimes they don't but there is a
humor element and i think that's some
things with what marvel wanted in this
is that yeah we're gonna go dark we're
gonna go violent at times we're going to
get we're going to scare you but we're
also going to make you laugh and there
was so many times in the audience i'm
looking to left and right of me and
people were chuckling and laughing out
loud at some of the comebacks and some
of the lines and even some of the more
scary parts of the movie because
they have these elements into it and
benedict plays this very well and i can
see why actors love working with sam
raimi because this is just a
it's like kids in a sandbox going play
with any toy you want do anything you
want and we'll make it work
and it's kind of like that uh christina
palmer rachel mcadams is such a she's an
integral part of this film and if you
saw what if especially the doctor
strange episodes you know how integral
christina is to dr strange's storyline
and that is very relevant here and they
do have such great chemistry off another
but um it works really well i don't want
to get much away but i think uh fans are
going to be pleasantly surprised how
it's
interwoven into it and how it works um
what are things i can talk about that
are in the trailer
the illuminati you are going to be
introduced to the illuminati of sorts
and i will say that um
it's going to shock some of you how it's
portrayed i think some comics fans out
there will love it some may not
there is you know like with anything in
the marvel cinematic universe they take
elements from the comics and they make
it their own when they do a film like
this or any film for that matter and you
do see that in this so i would say don't
be so hung up on the comics going into
this you know free your mind and just
be
okay
because there's gonna be some elements
that are gonna shock you and there's
gonna be some elements that you might be
like why do they do that or oh my god
they did that
i can't believe they did that and there
were gasps in the audience at times
going i can't believe this movie went
there
and it did
so
i'm just kind of setting expectations
for you on that all right okay
it's just a spectacle it is a visual
spectacle and i can see why they
probably had to do reshoots because they
probably want to cover some things and
you can see sometimes the continuity is
a little bit off here and there but
that's minor technical things but um
yeah it's really an interesting film and
you know when i we were with a group of
people watching this and some people
walked out going
they loved it they were like oh my god i
want more of this and some people were
like i need to process a little bit i
need to kind of maybe sit back and think
about this film again again because it
is different from the first doctor
strange it's very different from
avengers infinity war and end game
um it's just uh it's its own beast all
together it really is it's fascinating
now let's talk about america chavez um
she is also an integral part of this
film her character as you see from the
trailers and from the comics she has the
ability to open up portals in the
multiverse and travel through the
multiverse so that is something that
somebody wants very badly in this film
and they will do whatever it takes
to use that power
so she is sort of the uh
i would say the macguffin in some ways
to this um the dark hold as well is also
a big factor into this and we saw a
little bit of that in one division and
it plays a major factor in this film as
well and you see that sort of in the in
the trailers so you are going to get
elements of this mysticism this magic
good versus bad multiverse all that come
into play marvel does explain the
multiverse quite well in this so if you
had any reservations
they do explain it but i don't think the
multiverse will be for all audience
members watching marvel movies some of
those uh that just want more simplistic
storylines
maybe going huh i don't quite understand
what's going on here how does this work
how does that work how do the rules work
in this it is a little bit confusing
because the movie's only two hours and
five minutes
you may need to watch this again to
fully understand the multiverse and how
it works but they do a pretty good job
of explaining it for the most part
but i will say that um
yeah this is going to be a wild ride
folks it really is and i will give a
more spoiler review uh coming up in the
few days because i want everybody to
watch this first i mean other reviewers
will probably say the same thing watch
this don't read the internet
blogs or forums or reddits stay off all
that stuff just go in there with a fresh
mind really enjoy the film if you really
enjoy it or if you like this kind of
stuff but it is different it is dark it
is a little bit violent and that's why
it's a pg-13 rating so it may not be for
young kids it's a little it's got a
little those horror elements into it but
it is going to take you for a ride that
you did not expect going into this
anyway those are my thoughts on doctor
strange in the multiverse of madness let
me know your thoughts in the comment
section below what are you looking
forward to most if you've seen the movie
what are your thoughts on it try not to
spoil uh the film for anybody in the
comments okay we want to keep it clean
we want to keep it easy so everybody can
enjoy the film like we just did so with
that guys subscribe to the channel if
you can like this video helps us out a
lot take care stay safe and i'll chat
you soon bye
[Music]
you